greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by oh hello - she calm why have a dirty
ass when you could [ __ ] have a
portable bidet number two this podcast
is also brought to you by the ridge let
me tell you something Ridge wallet I
have fallen in love with this thing
alright the ridge is a minimalist front
pocket wallet that helps you really
eight you everyday carry it's launched
by a father-son team funded on
Kickstarter in 2013 the original resides
in the pockets of over a quarter million
men and women okay it's the
rfid-blocking wall is made by two metal
plates either titanium carbon fiber or
aluminum bound together by a durable
elastic bond band and it's tremendous
especially if you're a traveler listen
the ridge is minimal and its front
pocket and it's designed to let you
ditch your bulky wallet what we're gonna
do will here the church is this I'm
gonna give you a 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping by going to Ridge
wallet coms last Church again that's
Ridge wallet coms last Church again
that's used cloture CH when going to
Ridge wallet comm slash Church this
broadcast is also brought to you by on
it will a tremendous Black Friday deal
but who gives a [ __ ] about Friday
it's [ __ ] Wednesday you know
that there were guys in the gay
community who mixed ecstasy with viagra
or something crazy and put it in their
[ __ ] with a turkey roaster the turkey
basin okay
you mix my a go with whatever [ __ ] what
happened yeah do you see me [ __ ] jump
up and down with a feathered Sudan have
no idea I don't know the guy never
[ __ ] told me but just the thought of
putting drugs in your [ __ ]
that's your saying now
that's actually way more intense it's
more intense to put marijuana in you
[ __ ] I'm not doing all right those
days are done shocking you Sophie at 17
at 17 you can solve me on that [ __ ] they
put marijuana in your [ __ ] Oh ray I'm
walling I'm all [ __ ] in you know then
yeah take this [ __ ] mutely
Happy Thanksgiving to you [ __ ]
you're on a plane right now sitting in
the car thinking about your org think
about how much longer am I gonna [ __ ]
sit in this car with this [ __ ] kid
next to me stinking and yelling and
screaming that's the holiday season
that's all this if you fly now you gotta
be [ __ ] crazy like if you fly now and
sit in the back of the dungeon
next to the [ __ ] people with masks on
and [ __ ] you know one of those plane
like they got a mask on next to you I'm
[ __ ] comfortable ain't like triple
what it normally cost and there's a
[ __ ] takes his shoes off in the
back with some guy you see Southwest
they finally lost a case the lady got
sucked out of the [ __ ] window plane
tickets gonna go down again wait no no
no about six months ago a lady flew out
of Southwest window next day then it's
like no announcement they just put
everything on sale for $69 like nobody
gave a [ __ ] about the lady for $69 and
your luggage is free you get every Porto
Rican in the world going on that [ __ ]
plane luggage is free you ever see those
people they bring their own water they
bring everything they don't want to lift
the [ __ ] dime these people wait I
understand so what happened to this
woman who sucked about some woman on
Southwest there was a defective plane
there was a woman pilot flying which
saved the flight she she they just
released a recording of her saying lord
help me and then she landed the flight
but before that something happened the
engine busted and it caused some type of
something on the plane the engine part
that blew up hit the window and she got
sucked out of the window the actual a
woman they tried to hold her through
from her legs and [ __ ] it was really
scary and they landed the flight and
and two days later Southwest sound of
[ __ ] summer fail no announcement no
we're sorry about the loss on Twitter
just hey they're probably trying just
like push it under the rug Buffalo for
3950 yeah who the [ __ ] wants to go to
Buffalo give a quality Airlines and time
you want to go to Buffalo leave and ask
you why you me quality and I love
Buffalo I'm not putting you down I'm
just letting you know when you call
American Airlines do you know I want to
go to Buffalo they're like wizard
let me try Disneyland why do you go to
Buffalo for whoa why do you want to do
this I love I love it I [ __ ] love
Buffalo
I [ __ ] love Buffalo this savage is a
big savages
so what's going on with you talk to you
don't tell the world who the [ __ ] Mickey
Agrawal is you're saying okay great
okay born raised Montreal Canada okay I
joined up in the States
I went to college in upstate New York
and graduated 2001 what kind of bachelor
science which is basically means like
Moses imagine going to college where
you're gonna have to suck dick the rest
of your life for years I'm still gonna
bump it to Harvey along the way I don't
think you're a dick college studies okay
you're gonna get those George ready
Binaca Listerine like a [ __ ]
women's studies with your [ __ ]
crazies America you gotta come out with
two guns if you're a woman nowadays it's
true it really is it really is I mean
you never want guns anywhere no but it's
really weird how I have a five-year-old
daughter yeah I have to decide now after
what I'm learning in society who raised
that daughter how to prep her for the
[ __ ] savages that are out there
because of now you both sitting there
good one how did this happen mm-hmm and
that's the worst really in the [ __ ]
war yeah no for sure so you have to look
at your children look at the times you
know when I came from Cuba they raised
me to be an animal you know I was raised
on 88th Street in New York
city he'd being arranged V&M he mom
tells you not to cross Broadway waiting
to add those hands in those days and
told you nine eight seven really I told
you dick it was just a yellow light you
pick your chances it was like bingo
there was no hands if you would death
[ __ ] you you died he didn't know dick
there was no to count off
there was no you across the street now
there's nothing a TAC 205 West 88th
Broadway to Broadway there was no [ __ ]
how many times you get hit who me yeah
but three or four but you don't stop
yeah I didn't know about the Jewish
attorney that do that if I do about the
Jewish attorney think I'd be doing about
Amsterdam cigarettes lit I know almost
all those advertisements about like if
you get you know injured then it's just
like car like the old steam they're
trying to pick a [ __ ] scared right
now you know you're dying from asbestos
but you know what man if you grew up in
New York but if you went to New York
between the last ten years you breathe
that's best oh that's a city built on
[ __ ] as best those New York
everything the water I drank the water
when I was back there and I'm gonna tell
you something your digestive systems a
lot better down there when you live in
New you like I went to New York I was
[ __ ] like a meal every three hours
to to footage I wish I had to she
portable with me like a portable digi
just to wash my ass right there I'm a
[ __ ] spot but I went through this
Chinese plane I got a poopoo platter
wait 20 minutes before I went home and
blew up the [ __ ] bathroom
I blew it up and then when got coffee
and blew it up again like a savage
there's usually I don't [ __ ] on the road
my [ __ ] is very you know it knows
savvy
he's very generic what I'm saying like
he'll dump four inches here eight inches
here do you use tissue but then Sunday
not on the road cuz you got to carry it
and declare it you imagine telling the
people with duffle is this is my a
portable [ __ ] watch it and they're
like okay yes I hear right now we got
away
imagine breaking this down at PSA so
listen here's how it works yeah like my
[ __ ] really Queen they just be
looking at Joey shiny not the smell you
wash your ass and then you dry it you
smell the towel still smells like ass
even if you wash your ass when I was
ring
well I cuz I'm not sure I don't really
go I'll go I don't really travel that
much and I have the bidet I use it all
the time yeah every time I'm in a hotel
I'm like this doesn't grow this is
terrible it it is easy enough to do that
you could travel travel with you really
wanted to explain things to people if it
doesn't lean no but that's the thing you
I mean like people know what a bit not a
lot people don't know too bad a is but
but if you've traveled to anywhere in
outside the United States and in Europe
or Asia
bidets are everywhere everywhere every
single look there are two floors of like
dedicated to bidets in like many malls
in Japan a hand comes out and washes and
dries your [ __ ] for you you don't have
to say none right and like cousin it
just ran comes out wipes yes like in
Japan they got everything like that the
water the spring thing they have hot
thing that the boy - everything exactly
the China you got a [ __ ] in the hole
boys like you [ __ ] owe the money to
India - yeah when I was a kid with the
Puerto Rico my mother had a partner a
Puerto Rican partner yeah you like him
the book meet him Megan I operation yeah
I loved him with his wife Delilah and I
love their daughter Evie and every year
we'd go to Puerto Rico but they were
originally from the town called mojito
where there was no bathrooms in the
homes they just had outhouses and I
remember staying there for two nights
and like not [ __ ] like I went to look at
the outhouse and I saw crab and climbing
on the side and then I was like I'm not
[ __ ] so my mother had to get a hotel in
the Paula say and we had to drive like
an hour for me just just to [ __ ] and
they had no hot water this is well in 60
we won here something you want to hear
but unfortunate fun fact about that how
you have to wait for how long an hour
before you go washer or clean your butt
or go to the bathroom how long did it
take you said you have a driver come out
an hour door well so did you know that
Mullins of women are having to hold in
their pee in their poop all day and
basically wait too late at night but
when it becomes dark and then travel in
groups sometimes up to five mile just to
relieve themselves where is this India
Africa all over the world in the
developing world where there's no access
to clean toilets it's a real thing so
people have to actually not drink enough
fluids or eat enough food especially
when women specifically because there's
nowhere for them to go and defecate and
they just get raped how did you come up
with this whole trishy thing what made
you get involved with it
oh yeah well from scratch great um
there's you are the CEO I'm the founder
boom yes yes so the story of Toshi's I'm
half Japanese half Indian and both
cultures grew up with the days in Japan
they have those super fancy toilets that
have the hand that comes out and wipes
your ass for you and like washes it for
you and then dries it's the whole thing
it's very expensive but you know
Japanese high-end toilet and in India
they're they have these things called
the bum guns the Lota's what it looks
like literally like a hose that you just
kind of like move your hand and spray
your backside and kind of sprays it
really hard in India they could they
towel dry so both cultures grew up with
bidets and growing up in Canada and now
living in the United States for a really
long time both like the fact that that
there doesn't exist an option to wash
yourself and only use dry paper and so I
basically did a lot of digging into this
and realized that and I don't know if
you know this but toilet paper is
brought to America in 1890s and it was
popularized by these the brother Scotts
brothers like Scott's paper and Charmin
and these are the families that had lots
of money to spend on creating this new
product that can wipe your butt but if
you think about it like would you would
you go to your shower go to your
bathroom jump in the
shower not turn the water on and use dry
paper to wash your body does it make
sense right like would you like go to
your sink and not turn the water on and
like say you're cooking like a like a
like a chicken that's got like [ __ ]
you know like bacteria what do you call
that Salmonella on it mad you just take
dry paper and wipe it off then put it
back in your cupboards it's like people
will call you crazy right that's not
clean so the fact that we're still we're
using dry paper to wipe the dirtiest
part of our bodies it just doesn't make
any sense and actually it's causing 30
million in exacerbating 30 million cases
of chronic hemorrhoids UTIs yeast
infections for men who use wet wipes it
causes anal fissures anal itching all
these gross things because think about
you're sitting on poop fecal matter all
day long which causes infection disease
it's like it actually that [ __ ]
actually does spread and so what I
noticed was that the Japanese toilets
were way too expensive nobody wants to
like spend thousands of dollars on a
toilet plus plumbing plus electrical for
this day thing that they don't really
know much about and they don't wanna
have a like a spray gun in their
bathroom and so what I and also the
French bidets are those weird squat
things next year have a good day yeah
those like squat think we just shimmy
over with your booty my jersey right
when we moved to Jersey that was the
bathroom did the [ __ ] and her face
this way right then I would have to get
up turn around and sit and the thing
that yes so but it was interesting
because as a kid yeah this [ __ ] may turn
the water on and I had my own little
fountain right after you take you [ __ ]
you just hop off and let the hot water
hit you but the first time I didn't know
what it was and I'm looking at it and
they turn the water on to hit me right
in the [ __ ] face oh my god that's how
you discover one of the days
but then I got hooked on it right from
but the thing is we moved in the house
and I was ten and by 11 to 16 I was
hooked on that bidet right I loved just
clean yeah totally and then I would
scoot my foot back a little bit
you get the balls nice and watch in case
you bump into a victim why that I'd let
my penis a leave the pelvis and then you
go back you get up get out dry
everything and every day because I come
from humid Ville what does that mean I
come from New Jersey nice and I have a
[ __ ] shower phobia so I gotta take
three showers a day humidity makes me
crazy cousin I know my balls just wet
just in case you bump into somebody
that's the [ __ ] Anonymous meeting
you don't want your balls to be sticky
or bump into something they got stinky
balls yeah not a nice [ __ ] foundation
so I had I got hooked on the good day
after my mom died I didn't have a bidet
no really I didn't think i sat in a
bidet till three years ago in Las Vegas
Las Vegas at the hotel where I do the
residency right they have a good day
before this is before you experience
Joshy
the day yes it was about a year before I
experienced sushi amazing i remember i
sat there going like wow like this is
better than a turn up your ass this is a
real true [ __ ] no but it's so
interesting because there's such a real
blockage for for americans to use a
bidet they so know there's historical
contact so first of all a French person
invented the bidet and so the English
hate the French and therefore they were
like we're not we think the days are
just like this it was the Statue of
Liberty
well yeah but a waste of [ __ ] time
right so then so then during World War
two when American soldiers went to
Europe and fought in World War two they
would go to French brothels when they
were in France and they would see bidets
in French brothels and they associated
the days is something sexual and
something phallic and something you know
that was against puritanical America and
so as a result when they came back they
were like we are not bidets are dirty
and disgusting we refuse we are not
importing bidets but were importing
pizza that's when really Americans you
know found pizza and brought it back to
America so they basically accepted pizza
and shunned bidets and since then like
as buildings got built
you have something to say okay yeah I'm
very I'm very intrigued yeah well I mean
it's it's actually it's actually
fascinating when you when you understand
the historical context of why people do
something about people don't do
something it's kind of like you know why
why is it that we use Purell for our
hands and our total germophobes I mean
they looked it up like Purell cells 200
million bottles a month you know to
people who are like so germaphobic and
yet when it comes to their ass they're
not they're literally doing what people
did in the 1800s okay I washed my ass
before I touch my dick wash my hands
before I touch my ass holes I'm one of
those guys yeah like I'm clean all the
way well so why do you think people have
an adopted today in your opinion um they
just don't know it the same reason why
people don't try surfing maybe there's a
phobia stigma attached to it yeah people
always like oh well [ __ ] spray
everywhere I'm like no water hit you in
the ass damn I like it right right they
have a bar opiate it's a gay boy you got
a tent there anything goes in there it's
true no it's true homophobia did play a
big role in that
yes I think that for sure I think that
people men will go on why would I want
my [ __ ] clean I'm not a [ __ ] gay
dude my ass has to have that Wang
through it not my wife won't like it I
think it's disgusting I'm a clean
[ __ ] that's why I like the whole
concept I believe in being clean yeah I
mean so what's what's really what I what
I feel what I take pride in and with
with Toshi is that it's it's not a
multi-thousand dollar product it doesn't
require plumbing or electrical it's $69
anyone can have one and you know and
when and you can attach it to your
toilet in ten minutes
something straight I mean yeah when the
American soldiers are fighting and they
went to the French brothels those bidets
would not use just to watch ass they
were used for quickies in between I
heard my mother say a thousand times
how she would wash a [ __ ] in the bidet
in Spanish on the phone their
girlfriends
why come on [ __ ] wash it is [ __ ] wash
yeah if you get something shot in it and
you want to you know you don't want to
drip it at the office an hour later you
got a little bit day there but I mean
like pre sex I he dies in the midday
nobody knows nothing the truth no it was
used in France is a quick [ __ ] wash in
between [ __ ] what do you call them
cliffs when it when they call guys that
[ __ ] John John John
yes I mean like yeah but that's a good
thing we're to keep yourself clean I
think I believe like it's actually I
feel like well good for them for like
maintaining no that's it you know yeah
yeah you know you know high-priced
hookers go to the doctor once a week and
check out this monkey you charging a
thousand bucks for monkey they gotta
check it out make sure it's clean
there's no you know lankey it's got
condom residue you know so you gotta
[ __ ] keep your motor clean if you I
heard this one time my Qantas or say
that there it's safer to have sex with
them and then even though they get
tested every two weeks yeah yeah they go
to the doctor you gotta keep you in
shape
that's your breathing rate if that's
your business I mean if I was a porn
star I have a [ __ ] portable tissue no
totally and actually it's interesting
that you were talking about that is
because you know we just did a
partnership with aza Akira who's the top
tremendous I know a great friend
yeah she's a [ __ ] and by the way she's
in me I've never met her so we're gonna
partners just using a partnership with
aza we created a product called the AUSA
wash and and if you go to the AUSA wash
comm check it out
and by the way Oh for tushy don't go to
Toshi calm because that is a porn site
right go - hello - hello
alright so we're thinking back to the
invention of how about this yeah yeah
yeah so engineer
yeah yeah so we released you did the
whole thing you put the investment in
the time yeah I mean it
we found a manufacturer in Asia who
already made the days and so we just
told that we want it to look like an
iPhone like a really cool you know
a familiar shape that people in America
really felt comfortable with and the
shape of the smartphone you know was a
really familiar things that's in
people's hands 24/7 and so we wanted it
the product to have the shape of of an
iPhone and so and so that now when you
put on your toilet it looks like an art
piece instead of some weird contraption
that makes you feel like something's
wrong with you so what you did you
launch to issue um
2006 well 2016 really had a grand launch
really yes we're still pretty new and
what's interesting is that more and more
people are like oh my god the bidet
makes so much sense like like from an
environmental perspective it saves 50
million trees from getting flushed down
the toilet every single year to like
make toilet paper that actually doesn't
properly clean you you know from a cost
perspective like every month you're
spending at least $20 on toilet paper
and all this stuff which only makes
these huge companies like Procter &
Gamble billions of dollars but for us
like the the average working American
that $20 a month goes along laughs you
know think about it after ten years
that's thousands of dollars and so to
really be able to you know create
something that can in three months you
get paid back at $69 product so you're
washing your butt properly saving you
like ailments and dealing with doctor's
visits for hemorrhoids and [ __ ] and then
after three months you're pay back and
so all that toilet paper you're using
you know you you cut that down by 80%
you stopped a pat dry you can use toilet
paper to pat dry or we have organic
bamboo but towels like they do in Italy
where they don't use toilet paper they
use towels so that's another way of
doing it but you know to start off like
we'll ease you in use a bidet you tryto
see or whatever you want whatever bidet
product and and then to pat dry you can
use eighty percent less demand oh what
the [ __ ] you know or just view like an
angle dry yeah I love it because they
have it in the back bathroom and my wife
and I always forget to put paper in the
back bathrooms I don't worry about that
now I go back there with confidence I
got the hell out pushy
I get the nut sack in there boom
everybody's happy
and
time to meditate when hot waters hitting
your ass with water something happens to
your mind it's like wait a second you
contemplate do I really need to go to
Santa Monica [ __ ] those people do I
really need I'm sitting here cold ones
at my ass there's not a problem in the
world at home even if we get hit by even
if the Korean sends over a bomb in this
little bomb shelter right it sprinkled
in my ass I just thought when we showed
it to me I was in shock because really I
was ready to figure out how to get a
bidet like I was already in the process
of troubling my wife like the next place
we move we have to install a bidet I
know would be 3 or 4 grand you gotta cut
floors right move [ __ ] Oh huh but to
have a bidet in your house is [ __ ]
changing so you don't have the 3 4 grand
you pop the portable [ __ ] hello tushy
in and it works just to say yeah how
long we have are like two years yeah
correct and use it every day it's like
life-changing honestly like the fact
that like I just can't it's like it's
like in 1890s people used like like like
dry paper to wipe their teeth down
that's why people were like having
cavities and all these issues and like
black teeth and teeth falling out and
then they invented the toothbrush and
then during like the early 1900s and
it's like the fact that we're like they
invented the toothbrush and then didn't
solve the [ __ ] toilet paper situation
is just so interesting to me so you're
still doing what you did in the 89 swipe
your ass but to brush your teeth we
create the toothbrush let's go back to
the Indian because usually an Indian
shakes your hand with their right hand
right but if they hate you they hate
they shake can with your left because I
can see you're a piece of [ __ ]
they just supposedly went to hand with
their hand yes
they don't use toilet paper yeah they
just watched that's why wouldn't they
only use their one hand to eat as well
that's why when you hit the lottery at
the lotto place they had the bomb gun
left hand shake is giving you the kiss
of death maluca
they definitely use toilet paper here
don't they I don't know well no no they
they have they have they have some guns
the low ties so they basically they
basically a hose that sprays your ass
who sprays it them they do it's a weasel
that's the thing but it's a really
uncomfortable reach-around situation you
know a chubby guy yeah it's like you
know your [ __ ] backup people know
people people I was watching her on
stage major you could tell there's no
way she could reach around and wipe her
because you were coming on it I went
this morning oh yeah no you a woman has
to buy one of those extenders to
actually know they're for really really
like you know obese people that you have
to actually buy an extender to wipe your
ass because they can't they can't reach
around so you actually have to buy it
like a stick that pinches paper toilet
paper and then you kind of like try to
rub back their day for those people are
really much more about 8:30 is me oh my
god she was standing so by this time she
had moved and then they want to be like
a 60-minute type guy I took a picture of
her I said I said it and I just thought
about hello pushy which is the perfect
advertising so how about to see the
extended xxx version it looked bigger
than 300 pounds and you want us all to
be clean and as like the thing I like
what that won't do you have to extend
your cheeks also I get the certain way
that's to get the maximum oh I rock back
and forth when I rock back and forth to
your raucous I rock what I don't you use
a thing and just like let it do it yeah
oh come on I know me I'm half a doctor I
don't have no problems you know why I
had a back bathroom so I open the door I
close the door that leads into my office
and I smoke pot holy [ __ ] so every time
you call you just draw ah there's no
time ji Mian cut no more he just comes
all out ha ha why are you clapping
choking ah here we gone into
water like a shark ba-ba-ba-ba-ba and
then you turn the hello fishy oh nothing
everybody's happy right I was kind of
disappointed when he gave me the cold
when I was a girl maybe I'll order the
hot water one I like the cold
I liked that one too I use a cool one
too actually I didn't even hook up my
warm and cool one because and in by the
way if you bought the warm and cool one
agent want to hook it up you could
actually just still use it for the cool
water 100 medium yeah be on fire then
you leave the house I like it nice and
cool listen it wakes me up I like it but
it's like no it's like room temp you
know it's like mines cold it's been
chilly around here lately months oh I
like it yes I cry out there out there
vegan right I went through this
afternoon with the kraut their name and
well if I go to crowd therapy I always
think about how I used to go to a gay
bar in the eighties in New York all
ramrods that's why I used to buy
quaaludes Gorilla Biscuits
what are quaaludes again our Cosby pills
but I know I know
before Cosby [ __ ] disgraced and ran
them through the PAC money
quaaludes were a fun drug everybody the
Gorilla Biscuits they were fun Gorilla
Biscuits and I would go down there and I
saw and dad three floors of Gaede them
you know that lesbians gay guys in that
like a fetish floor wow you know an
alley but the thing I remember one time
was a guy telling me that he got his
dick sucked the night before by a guy
when I excuse us not any liked it oh
yeah he doesn't mouth was cold it was
tremendous and I'm thinking about how
that guy really invented cryotherapy
even even know it
suck this dick invented crowd therapy
without knowing that guy I thought if
you use ice cubes it made it shrink I
don't know let you suck a good dick
right and it's the highest crushed ice
right White Castle ice White Castle give
you ice cubes they give you that crushed
ice you could suck a pipe and without
scratching a dick you're a [ __ ]
professional
not for nothing more family you talk
about
I'm saying we should break it up when
Grandma comes yeah [ __ ] em Oh is grandma
coming on the show no grandma's dead and
buried the grandma dead and buried in
Havana Cuba someone oh cool
yeah poor [ __ ] nine kids never got
nothing for dieting communism what have
you been back no not since they opened
it you haven't either
yeah I don't know what my problem is I
don't know you know it's like 23andme
and I know those things for some people
they can handle it for some people they
can't have why what's your what's your
breakdown I loved it I loved doing 23 of
me but I have a friend that found out
that his grandmother had an affair hmm
so now they call it the grandma [ __ ]
they going to the grave and throwing
flowers on and on it oh my god that's a
23andme did to that [ __ ] family oh
it's one of those [ __ ] things come on
it's right in there okay wait so what
are you what percentage of you are is
they had the personally I'm from the
Upper Peninsula of Spain like 50% is
from Spanish blood then I had West
African blood I had Chinese blood from
when the Chinese went around the world
and they found that DNA I have some of
that DNA a little Russian Jew on that
said there was something off West
African the Lord kept in Spain they call
it something they have a name for that I
don't mind doing 23andme but if you're
gonna find that your uncle's your
[ __ ] father
it's not gonna help no no I get no I get
that
so yeah that's Carole the last time
conversation zoom it's about his grandma
[ __ ] a Cuban guy instead of [ __ ]
the grandpa that's why the Cuban it's
[ __ ] this thing whoa and maybe like
what are the key are the grandkids now
like sure yeah everybody's [ __ ] a
shock like nobody knows nothing none not
really knows why they [ __ ] they're
like fried bananas you know now
everybody knows bongo drums they got a
certain urge to get up and dance
you know Zayn
for years they thought they were Italian
it's like wow we see the commercial with
the kid that comes out hi my name is
Louie you could tell that guys like a
team dicks he's like I thought for years
I was something else but I'm really a
town you know charlie nobody's gonna
claim you all right Louis knock it off
so that commercial
with the white chick with the half a [ __ ]
boyfriend was rolled up for years I
thought my name was I was Irish you know
my my my well I kept missing husband
it's my first time saying really husband
like out and really and we just got
married but um he just found out he was
Jewish only a few years ago as well and
relations I know and then he was like oh
you mean he found out his his dad his
dad had kept it a secret because his it
was it's a long story
but his dad's family his dad's family
were anti-semites and they then that
found out that they were Jewish they
sold the information for the Nazis their
own mother for a dollar what's so crazy
with the suit
Jews the [ __ ] up that means that that
deals with the Nazis you don't wanna be
around either oh my god that's quite a
movie yeah well I mean he wouldn't soon
as he found out he found there's a free
trip to go to Israel if you're a fight
if you find out you're Jewish it's
called birth right yeah
and free on the free everything
everything have to be a they want young
people to move there so yeah I think I
think I had already been sorry I wasn't
allowed to do it but yeah let's bring my
friend Max's uncle created birthright oh
and so yeah and then and then Andrew
went on birthright as soon as he finally
just like free trip to Israel so
tomorrow if I do 23andme and I know
somebody down there and he pushes the
gays over 50% 23andme on Israel I think
he under 30 are the 30 percent 30 years
old
I'm gonna be the Jew you gonna put an
age restriction I'm saying I got you now
I get the long sideburns I got a black
jacket what's the [ __ ] little hat I
borrow the little [ __ ] key we had
yeah well dandruff on my shoulder
yeah 18 to 32 well the [ __ ] ripoff
Dave at least one Jewish parent what the
[ __ ] what kind of things is that yeah
what a capable latisha Kayden she's his
Puerto Rican Jew on Facebook she'd be
all right well I grew up in Montreal and
Montrell there's big Jewish population
actually surprisingly did not know that
but it was so how to [ __ ] agenda up
in school in upstate New York maybe you
go to prison I know might well my
parents my parents are a very Asian and
they were like you cannot leave Canada
very Asian my my mom is from Japan like
off the boat and they look really I know
when I met you you're like Mickey I
thought your reply I thought you were
black name like Kiwi Michael walk Mickey
I'm like she's gotta be black but you
married a black dude something's going
on here
you think you got a job at Benihana you
wanna [ __ ] he's got it by the job
kinda getting a job at Benihana you
don't look nothing Japanese wrong your
sister looks more Indian
yeah it's very beautiful thank you oh
yes no Japanese you look a little
Japanese yeah she's a child she after
you smoked the reefer okay Molly you
started bowing and [ __ ] you [ __ ]
valley the rickshaw you pull up I can't
wait that that much money they just have
a Rachel it's just gonna win mean for
you that's my fantasy I don't want to
say these I don't want to Porsche I
don't want to jet I don't want to plane
I want a [ __ ] rickshaw yeah I'm in
the HOV Lane Japanese guy in good shape
just running down the 405 that service
pulling up and [ __ ] Danny's [ __ ]
take you years to get everywhere no one
these Japanese made all [ __ ]
have you ever seen them how they run
with a rich oh [ __ ] 140 miles an hour
what this guy's at the comportment that
drive you around and bicycles and I see
them they're in shape
yeah they got a bike with 300 pounds
they got me then two [ __ ] minutes
workout so yes so my dad with me it's so
interesting you said rickshaw in a
Japanese person running cuz my dad's
from India and that would be like a
perfect mix japanese guy riding in the
indian rick shots i mean wonderful so my
dad would I know pimping [ __ ]
straight out of what's that movie they
made they would be like no millionaire
Slumdog Millionaire was into the the
mountain of poop that was a that was a
nod to the global sanitation crisis but
anyway no I am but yes I might my pet
so my parents my father came to this
country from India with five dollars in
his pocket I read those I know right
like we don't brand good well he did
anybody he had to buy you had to go like
Salvation Army and like buy a jacket
with it so he really didn't have any
money so so when we like you know going
to go to college in Montreal was really
cheap you know thinking about wow
[ __ ] weird is that line that every
immigrant including myself uses but it's
true yeah actually my grandfather came
this country with a thousands pocket
well I hope you suck dick because my dad
my god after to take out a $50 loan to
go take my mom out to dinner
cuz when he met her he had no money and
he wanted to you want to take her out to
dinner and so he took out a $50 loan
this is back in 1974 so $50 was a lot of
money and he took out a loan and Phil I
had to fill out like 40 pages of
paperwork to borrow $50 to take out my
mom where and in well he was it from
India and he was taking out my mom but
he didn't where was the in cantonment in
Ottawa at Carleton University yeah and
so anyway so it's a beautiful story so
anyway so so in Montreal the cost to go
to college beautiful story
he brought 50 dollars he took home for a
handshake he didn't even get a look
cookie ambassador well my mom $50 mama
she Japanese yang you and that nobody
did it here right she didn't give it up
- 48 she said that I was going on with
two dollars you got blue balls
this is hot Japanese chick you want to
keep drinking that sake I kept pushing
the sake like Cosby but nobody was
drinking oh my god well so they met and
actually it is a beautiful story they
they fell in love and it was like an
against all odds love story like my mom
you know she heard that her parents cut
her off financially if you know if you
marry this guy Indian loli guy okay and
my dad's family we're like we have an
arranged marriage for you you know in
India that would make us you know like
fine dowry and set us up so both sides
they were like [ __ ] what do we do and
they said [ __ ] it was marrying each
other but my mom said to my dad that she
wouldn't have sex with him or she
wouldn't have accent until she married
until he married her so they got married
within seven months and then they had
three of us in one year yeah so my older
sister's 11 months older than us and my
twin sister and I were born
yes you question yes you know your dad
you know a fooled around a little bit
before I was seven months something like
that you can't hold on forever you gotta
give you a sample of something nobody's
gonna marry you without a sample is up
you guys show me something I mean I
think it was my mom was pure but I don't
know she just admitted to me like not
too long ago that she took a puff of
marijuana smoke but she's like I did not
inhale I did not inhale she just like
she just puffed it out right away
oh my god one of our good friends in
Hollywood was Japanese and she also got
you know a follow on like a chopstick
company he was filthy [ __ ] rich the
guy had planes issue she wants to marry
[ __ ] Kunta Kinte and she ruins
everything she marries the black is
black
in Hollywood and they live in a [ __ ]
one-bedroom with three kids she could
have it all and the month she tell me
the whole story the mother would come
the father would stay in his Mercedes he
is not said a word since she married the
black that now the word makes a live in
a one-bedroom with three kids and
[ __ ] clue the context but that she
loved it or no huh
she'd have to she's a great lady I call
her MA her name is Messiah amazing come
on is she beautiful and she's got a
[ __ ] body that don't quit she's a
mama for kids wants to go to yoga 4 a.m.
I'd be snorting coke whacking off
looking outside the window and I see mom
with our yoga pants walking to yoga for
the morning I go miles of pieces as easy
but she was family I mean yes somebody
from Pisa
I still talk to her all together they're
still together she said no to like a
life that could have been just delivered
for her I mean that that's a that's a
real thing society still the mother jobs
aren't the father John often sits in the
[ __ ] car Wow go up check on the kids
she brings the kids down shows them the
kids grandpa you don't want to see her
and the kids were all have black with
Michael Jackson
yeah it looks like Prince so the
father's [ __ ] furious the whole time
he's playing with me not always playing
with stuff I listened races you know
that shit's too exist in the family yeah
I hear that you know prearranged I mean
half of us don't want to marry the
person will hooked up with you ever get
married and go on a honeymoon and go
what the [ __ ] would I do what the [ __ ]
would I do I didn't check out the
paperwork this [ __ ] noise you know
something you always flights up well in
the India and the Indian world in the
Indian world you only meet the person
like one day before or some person
horrible it's crazy
it's actually really [ __ ] up can you
amaze I can't imagine it's happening so
it was me me
you gotta marry a fat [ __ ] Cubans and
also you're like what the [ __ ] do I do
I better start cleaning the asses like
how we used to marry somebody you're not
attracted to I know it's crazy at all
Olivia I mean what so what you know and
like actually in like and I it's not
like a it's not like I'm [ __ ]
segwaying to like my book but I mean
what's interesting is that I you know
the reason why we like follow these
preconceived sort of paths is just made
up like everything's made up right like
the fact that like arranged marriages
like that was just like a thing that
someone decided was the way it was going
to be and then people were like alright
we agree you know like the same thing
with like everything in Our Lives
everything alone everything is made of
our conversation my 23 year old me's
yesterday about the job market you know
just regular conversational young girl
doesn't have a father I'm tight with a
mother my my wife is her aunt but I had
this and she was three rings she calls
me and we talked about the job market
and I got off the phone like and I
looked at my wife my son I go you know
the system ain't working no no one's
preparing you for being in the world
know the system a working app these kids
are coming out of college in debt and
there's nothing for ya right now my
daughter was 18 I'd have to sit her down
and go how about we got a deal let's cut
a deal you live in a house for you know
guys you could date you know just no
guys nice I don't to wake up the [ __ ]
cool begin in the living room no I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm not racist like that I'm
CUBAN I can be rich I'll pay the rent on
time make you car payment but you have
to get a job what yeah yeah I want you
to learn if you really want to be a
marine biologist
you'll learn after this one year in the
real world it helped me a lot I didn't
go to I didn't have the funds to go to
college I got a job selling cars and it
taught me about people I credit it
teaches you how to sell that's something
I've never lost and I think kids today
the old
softened but also like the world like
they're so coddled and you can't even
you can't even sit them down to like hey
that wasn't okay because then they'll go
to like the [ __ ] like like board and
be like they were rude to me
conversation I hope until I saw you or
anybody in the room when I was talking
about degrees now nothing bothers me
more when a guidance counselor abares
you yeah you know what I want to learn
woman studies to take it as a [ __ ]
minor I know okay pewter science it's
great that's great but unless you get a
job a bongo store you're not gonna
[ __ ] make a living in this life how
many African bongo stores there in LA
let's tweak them second it's like
history or so I don't agree no more it's
like I was prison I got a prison I got
married I had a kid I got a job and one
day when I was there ya go this is it
this is it well you know you know Horace
Mann created the school system create
the school system to basically churn out
factory workers right good they need to
create because like the Industrial
ushion was happening and all these
factories were forming and they needed
to teach people how to be obedient like
sheep and turned them in and turned them
out like cogs in the machine so if
someone didn't make you the factory like
to the factory they could just plop
somebody else in literally like a human
machine part and so the common school so
Horace Mann create this thing called a
common school where where he would
basically teach people where he taught
the teachers to teach the students how
to become like factory workers and think
like that and just conform them to the
societal ways of being and so that's
where all of this consumerist mindset
happened that's where all the
indoctrination and everything like
that's why the tables were in certain
rows and you know in those rows like
that that's to basically create these
factory workers are great obedient
students like the whole structure of the
school system was created specifically
for factory workers and now of course
2018 the fact that we're still churning
students in and out with these
standardized tests and all these things
that do not work and we know that it you
know there
a hundred percent there needs to be a
complete shift to be I think the
traditional high school four-year
college
come on debt credit cards handed to you
from every fight take your first school
loan yeah you're open game yeah you're
young and you're naive and your parents
tell you not to buy those [ __ ] shoes
on the credit card but you buy them
anyway
and now once a month you got to pay $34
for the rest of your [ __ ] life
yeah and it's we've all learned that
lesson but I think it's been you know
wheat you know I talked to Lee and I
gonna leave when you go to these
interviews
do they even talk to you about college
yeah yeah what's your work experience
what's your work expensive my niece's
beef was she's graduating you know Phi
Beta [ __ ] from the University of
Tennessee in noble Iowa so she says you
know she said what was your major
something like [ __ ] smart something
like genius [ __ ] but you have to have
experience so I mean I will say that you
know in my experience of even you know
hiring as an entrepreneur I mean your
startup and you need people with
experience and you're hiring a lot of
people right out of college which is
also great because you have to find
bright-eyed Bush
several different business yes they do
you have to she will I have Toshi I have
three restaurants called wild which you
should come to when you come to New York
they're gluten-free pizza places but I
can't let my people down migrants died
to bring that recipe over and you want
to take the glute not because your
stomach hurts go [ __ ] no three slices
and [ __ ] I just told you I almost killed
Lauryn Hill on the floor exactly that's
what we have we have cheese options that
you can eat that yeah we have a few
options we have we have non-dairy
cheese's and so we have cashew cheese
we've got no but but you're not gonna
then blow up the [ __ ] whole place I
don't give a [ __ ] if you put calf
[ __ ] cheese on a pizza I understand
we also have regular we have organic
mozzarella cheese as well okay so we
have what does that mean it means that
Counting get kicked I want the cow to
get a couple kicks to the head and they
no the serotonin goes into the cheese
you know no no there's like chickens you
ever tasted chicken hasn't been kick you
ever tasted chicken that's been kicked
[ __ ] delicious tender like dick it's
like this - what is this mushroom
chicken piccata with no piccata
you mean the chicken may get kicked a
couple times I'm not saying that value
you know I love you Peter
how do you know it has been cake because
you could taste them so you bite that
chicken cover you like this [ __ ]
chicken this [ __ ] they put them in a
cage to get and now there's a [ __ ]
Turkey recall days before [ __ ]
Thanksgiving Salmonella wash their asses
people washing about they just can't
come up with that many turkeys in this
it's too much I know they're just it's
the consisteth the whole whole system if
everything is no it's actually and it's
all [ __ ] and all made up like even
money is made up money is energy you
know made up energy exchange you know
it's actually like all of it is just
like [ __ ] made up let's go back to
the pizzas cuz she got me riled up
where's Pizza locations yeah I have to
in New York one in Brooklyn one in
Manhattan and I have one no no we
experienced hurricane sandy we went
through oh I like him throwing another
window like it's on a Hudson Street well
between Perry and Charles that's why you
get away with that [ __ ] 535 West Side
somebody throw a brick through your
window in the morning they want a pizza
a pizza
I'll [ __ ] kill no capital of repeat
that is it we have we have barbecue
chicken pizza we've oh yeah I have to
stab you a bayonet oK we've got we've
got margarita pizza
we've got no yeah we had what we have
like a white truffle pizza with
mushrooms it's really nice we've got
yeah we better push you to a pizza yeah
and it's up with it with a spite as a
price of spicy prosciutto we've got you
know we have
I want gluten the restaurant fortunately
it's a hundred percent gluten free no
20% of Americans eat gluten-free now
because a lot of people are actually
intolerant Micro and tolerances are
slightly allergic if they don't know it
and mobile annuity for a hundred years
I'll tell you why all of a sudden they
can't wait a thing no no I'll tell you
how the [ __ ] you know you free who the
[ __ ] told you go you do bloodwork uh-huh
you do bloodwork can you check it out
you ask your doctor this [ __ ] it would
be at a bar drinking one night having a
good time yeah then you have stomachache
it's [ __ ] everywhere no because gluten
today the way it's the way it's made
like the way that it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] I agree with you yeah you pizza
Paula
you know I'm listen I love it I thought
you were selling like you know well you
know what's this [ __ ] that my girl likes
the goat cheese you don't put goat
cheese great done no problem
oh geez well go I'll actually you know I
dare you to meet me there
and we all do a blind I'll put blindfold
on you and I'll do like a normal note
and gluten a gluten pizza and and then
our pizza and you won't know you won't
know the difference number one and
number two you'll actually tastier which
Lola no no but it doesn't it feels like
like actual like you're tasting you work
the restaurant - no you wouldn't
I ran them for seven years before I
brought up an amazing partner and who
it's amazing when you find the right
person to really think I love you did
that you Japanese and Indian you gotta
watch the register listen I got robbed
over four years no no I got robbed no
you're wrong put someone know I got
robbed a little Greek diner in New York
I know
mother's always there the only address
come Marley's not even their wives
[ __ ] my wife [ __ ] my wife the
mother's dead 12 hours a day with a big
zip with hair give a [ __ ] you gotta wake
him up to pay the bill why my mom I wake
up cheeseburger deluxe
if not Robi the death no I got robbed
for so many years but I got but Ghana
see I got robbed so long so and this
sounds really naive to say but I swear
to God like when I met with well leave
my partner who's [ __ ] amazing he's
good
well lead he's the best well he come on
me I [ __ ] love him so much anyway so
I met with him and my first question -
no he is Tunisian you got a pic a flag
okay you know so pizza I have an Italian
in this you [ __ ] Indian no usually a
Keynesian guy I can't buy a slice I just
can't sleep it buddy I can't buy a slice
of you okay no trust me I'm with my will
I will dice to my breast I will like
Hartnett ear restaurants Bon Jovi then
maybe I'll go no there's like it's
actually a skip a sponge everybody
thinks about well she's at the house
right now
yeah so so that was my that was my first
business and it's been around for 15
years before the sushi I was 25 years
old bless you yeah 25 minutes a lot of
gluten free from the beginning
hmm we were gluten free I just felt good
that's sexy
I um I'm sorry the restaurant Oh when
you're 25 oh yeah I was 25 years old I
open the restaurant no experience raised
250,000 you know just like like random
people and friends and family just like
people and you tell me the truth you
sleep in a no man no one of them might
have loved me but isn't that it kept
them on the string there you walk
cleavage would ya so no I mean [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] hard out there anyway but um so
so yeah the right I mean the restaurants
been going so I finally brought well
lead-in
and I at my first question to him was
like do you believe in karma I swear to
God I was my first question cuz I've
been robbed for so long and just dealt
like I felt so betrayed and so I said do
you believe in karma and his literally
this was his answer whenever I have a
bad thought a bicycle I don't know about
of my foot that's what he said and I was
like oh my god my second question was
like I was like are you are you the
genie from Aladdin because I was like I
felt like I met the God like the person
who wasn't good for me both the arrests
yeah at three we have one in Guatemala
as well a franchise yeah yeah we like
Jersey Connecticut you gotta go Brooklyn
New York
Guatemala like that's beep like that I
knew your pizza box
Brooklyn Guatemala who the [ __ ] I'm
saying
I guess usually Beverly Hills New York
in London this is 3 I don't know I know
it was like we ate a lot of pizza there
they well so they're very interested in
in the gluten free movement
interestingly enough and they want to
bring a gluten-free kind of fast food
but higher end restaurant concept to
Guatemala in like literally it's it's
it's kicking ass I've actually
personally never been but I get the
posts and the instagrams if you are it's
a guy they use your name or you often
while they use wild and with their
franchise yeah yeah yeah so that's thing
we got like we had like 80 franchise
inquiries over the last few years and it
was all people who like either read my
first book do cool [ __ ] and they were
like we love that we love the idea we'd
like we want to open one but they didn't
have any experience and so people you
know like we've known all the horror
stories people who don't have experience
trying to run a franchise is just like
the biggest nightmare and like you know
like walk to words you know like
destruction of your brand one of the
business do you have so yeah anyway
through French are that and so now it
was 15 years wild it's awesome come I'm
dare you I dare you to come
dare you look okay great and I will do a
blind test I swear to God no we're doing
I'm gonna do it I want just a margarita
no way that we've grated and you know
have a great time I'm gonna Radio City
to take the family perfectly I'll take
your whole people you have done and then
I started this period underwear company
called thinks period underwear
yeah period proof underwear we're not
gonna talk about that yeah and I mean
while you're here because yeah really
here what because my mother I used in my
job when I was four and five was to
clean the bar and stocked the ice and
fill the shelves and Albert will get
changed and stuff like that but I was
like a little half of fact cubed I
believe in my treasure hunters so I
would always like get a quarter in and
I'd make my own max and say look what I
found
I found this quarter and my mom knew I
stole it you know I was just thinking
what do you think I'm stupid and you
drew the map yourself I would wrinkle it
and burn the edges like I would burn the
edges to make it look like it was a man
oh they had a she had a bartender called
Pepin Ciego right Pepe but he was blind
so he wore the glasses so in Spanish
they called him it ca go Oh
one day they started [ __ ] me like to
me you know there's a treasure chest in
the ladies bathroom
come on no we can't tell you they [ __ ]
played me like a fool I feel like three
weeks though ain't no tell him about the
treasure so what'd you do my mother drew
a map and led me to the woman's bathroom
to the period box I stuck my hand there
thinking like there was like a hundred
mil in there I came out with a Kotex in
1970 you know Oh Oh Tex look like in
1970 well you look like oh they're nice
and thin because everybody's pussy's
nice and thin it's a little strip a
Kotex look like a [ __ ] brick could
weighed like eight pounds a woman had to
be an Olympic lifter well woman got a
period she backed out thrown out days
because a period when Kotex was thick
and when you bundled it up it was like
taking it out looking at it and smelling
it and going what the [ __ ] and then my
mom and the Pepe were laugh and I was
crying and I'm like there was no
treasure
uh woman's [ __ ] blood and all these
washing hands 18 times Hey after that I
don't [ __ ] with periods if you have your
periods we don't talk interesting call
me well you know without that you
wouldn't be here without period yeah I
used to have a girlfriend blow but I
wouldn't rock a coke from time to time
I'm monkey and she called me she'd get
drunk but I always knew her cycle and
whenever she called me it was like the
24th I would Nance the phone that she
would quote why don't you ever call me
back look I'm busy and you got your
period no you no good to me what am i a
sexist actually it's quite nice that's
disgusting
it's like murdering somebody while you
wake up this blood every way I do the
shower I did it one time and I got
painted you did I talked about today you
didn't talk to her today she's how she's
one of my dearest friends we moved here
together we were at a beach one time and
Seattle her and I had a Cove and it was
laying we talked about it today she was
laughing so she was crazy just like
uncle Joey but very hot ha ha ha she was
there was a stream in this place in
Seattle had a little caves you'd go into
and I was drinking a bottle with James
cuz I don't drink alcohol but I could
drink like a wine cool
I'm about third it's 1996 about 3334
she's about 28 she's [ __ ] bang I had
the data for like two years we talked
about this today looking at her ass at
the bikini I'm like I gotta try this I'm
licking the bottle in James bottle and I
just don't put it by a little monkey and
I'm just putting the bottle it's my
[ __ ] oh and I'm pushing a [ __ ] the
bottles empty right up so I'm putting it
by a [ __ ] and I'm rubbing it and she's
starting to breathe heavy and I open up
a thigh and I slipped a little bikini
over and I start taking the bottle cuz
I'm a savage and I put in a monkey and
I'm starting to just give it like little
low pushes hey look at mama she's
getting out of it she's like Joey's the
real [ __ ] deal he's a savage ah so
I'm a young guy I don't know what I'm
doing and I'm just giving her like a
little masturbate with the thing like a
build
and now she's going crazy I'm working
this [ __ ] and just a cue from
the bottle oh my god suctioned it
suction her period it was out like in
two days and I'm looking at the bottle
and also I'm seeing this brown blood at
the bottle oh my god and I passed out
she had to wake me up as I can't see
needles of blood I pass out she had to
wake me up my head was on a rock we
laughed about it today because she wait
she was telling me that the guy she
dates now does she called me today she's
like I've been thinking about you for
like a month I know what's going on and
she does because we dated 20 years ago I
was still like I'm a godfather to one
out of kids ah so she goes I was talking
cuz we talked about that reading mm-hmm
so she called me this morning I'm a
Marie T I'm riding before jujitsu I love
my new boyfriend but I like him because
it reminds me of you he choked me he
makes me look his balls and he whips me
and [ __ ] but he's got Edie was he he has
dead dick
oh he's 45 he's gonna do squats that's
what cures dead day you gotta do squats
what happened wait what happened me of
dead dick I think that's what she was
saying she's nothing is crazy for
starters she's crazy so she's like I
can't suck this dick for a half hour not
anything for me right yeah like she's
crazy she called me once and said she
went to the doctor I get it that she had
what's that [ __ ] no couple tunnel carpal
tunnel from giving hand jobs
she goes I got carpal tunnel from all
those years and in high school giving
out hand jobs I'm on the phone [ __ ]
dying so I even had to call the podcast
she said on the podcast she's the real
deal oh my god she called me out of the
blue and she goes I haven't talked to
you cuz I'm with a jealous guy and I
know that you called a few weeks ago she
goes he was me you [ __ ] tears me
apart you know he [ __ ] chokes me
pulls my hair but then when we go to do
it he's got Edie what should I do and
I'm out time to do squats I'm 55 I'm
still rocking and rolling because I got
squat it's got a do squat squats it's
the truth
look at watch dude look at what heavy
squats do to a man they change your life
you're not a fan I got listened
my wife for 13 years nothing happened I
got me so I didn't want to use Viagra or
any and no I don't want to use we're
gonna call them up and suggest viagra I
don't believe in that [ __ ] like I'm
crazy
who knows I'll take anything it scares
the [ __ ] yeah it's scary I need to pay
something for your victim I just told
you listen there's no sex but I'm gonna
suck the [ __ ] anus out of your anus
I'm gonna how old is she your [ __ ]
via [ __ ] text message you know saying
hello to see up close and personal
how the [ __ ] is a woman a mom
intelligent Chopin or businesswoman how
do you do it all and be so sweet and be
so down to earth
I mean how do you do it same thing no
you do it and you're kind of part of a
foo-foo world but your [ __ ] real like
your [ __ ] real like your real well no
I know you're infatuated with [ __ ] I
can't imagine what you could do with
your tongue forget about it you guys you
go to town you know saying are you doing
around the world isn't around the world
I'm in Tunisia I'm [ __ ] thinking
about karma my shoelaces what was the
last time you got a good around the
world week never that's what the [ __ ]
problem is that's why you walk around
with this is just an amazing woman then
and that way you would have a different
temperament to you because you're in New
York I think it keeps you a little bit
more grounded I made children be happy I
won 16 months yeah yeah I have a twin
sister and that that helps me to cuz any
time we both if either of us are like
not being exactly I mean like for art I
mean we've been together for 39 years
like every me my twin sister well I hope
so I didn't know she didn't pop up like
four you know but like about like living
in the same like within five blocks of
each other for our entire lives and so
we see each other
like everyday yeah that could see who's
your best yeah
and so and so when you have your mirror
you ever where you go it keeps you like
totally your so you got a [ __ ] she's
like yeah oh yeah no we caught no she
like like her she's the reason why she's
moving out of her apartment into and she
bought a house is because her apartment
did hurt their there weren't any only
buildings like in New York City that's
not compatible with toshi so she had
like she's had yeast infection she's a
deal with the [ __ ] and so she basically
bought a house that's compatible with
Toshi so she can have the days there's
like sometimes they're single units when
there's no tank and when the bowl and
the tank are like one small unit without
the you know how there's at the bowl
where you flush the toilet right when
there's no tank and it's like a little
flat just to basically seat with like a
little thing everyone's FEMA yeah
they're very very modern and not not
like very few places have them and her
in a new building that she was living in
happened to have those toilets so she
constantly had issues UTI issues now
with them being a mom and all this [ __ ]
how'd you write time to fight a [ __ ]
write a book I actually wrote this book
like I I went through some crazy [ __ ]
like over the last couple of years in
business just building a really big but
on top of this business [ __ ] you're like
that [ __ ] guy from Virgin Airlines
like you know instead of jumping off a
building you got a [ __ ] Burning Man
and feed [ __ ] people with tit milk
who does that not even the Peace Corps
does that even the Peace Corps you know
you don't waste liquid gold you were
featured as now where was your child
when you had this president was here my
know we are here hero was 8 weeks old
and he was with Andrews mother for just
that we were gone for like four days
whoa you just left a bunch of breast
milk for him yes I pumped for literally
three straight days and then you went to
Bernie went to Burning Man pumped their
cuz you used to you're welcome walking
around with the pumper and people making
cocktails and yeah but why
rushon let some blind guy Roblin his
eyeballs we could see oh well they say
never little it's actually liquid gold
actually cures a lot it's it's great for
your gut it's great for your system it's
a hangover cure it's gonna build muscle
while yeah I check that what she was
kind of when I was younger and that
freaked me out
she wouldn't squirt it in whatever the
[ __ ] it's amazing I don't like that
she's amazing I'll squirt in your face
you don't squirt money oh my god it's
worth my face but I'm a man's man away
The Rock Hudson wall did you know that
when a baby sucks on a mother's nipple
the baby's saliva sends a signal to the
nipple through the nipple to basically
create the exact concoction of breast
milk that the baby needs is deficient in
whatever vitamins are issued minerals
the breast milk will will like literally
like like a machine that we are like
produce exactly what the baby needs and
so when a baby's drinking formula which
by the way is important to do but like
back when we were growing up like
everyone was saying formulas way better
than breast milk like don't do breast
milk it was a whole thing but like for
most is not its supplemental there was
also other options on that options there
were also other benefits of
breastfeeding your child was a little
bit more confident they said your child
will be more intelligent yeah it was
like three or four things that were I
asked my mother you breastfed me she
goes [ __ ] yeah yes drinking the other
you were sucking out smoke yeah I mean
my breast number 14 months straight
knows the big commitment it's a lot yeah
yeah I think merci breast note for a
long time to my wife it was impressive
well I mean so yeah I mean back to like
I wrote the book because I was just
really I mean sort of frustrated with
was sort of the media world that we live
in the clickbait headline will [ __ ] take
down vibes that you know that we live in
and the way society sort of is still so
structured and so rigid and we're sort
of told how to think act and behave when
we can literally like you know like I
love you because you're so free
but like most people can't speak the way
you speak and in quotes get away with it
societally you know like this is you
know this is your world and this that
you created which is amazing but most
people don't feel the permission that
they can do that and like the the really
the sort of the the whole point of it is
to say that hey like you know society
was created by people you know people
like you and me but only like years past
and now of a sudden they dictate how we
should act and behave and even if it's
in authentically who we are it's just so
[ __ ] weird and you know also it's
like you know really thinking about the
fact that we really from the poor
graduate college the point we die there
are only 21,000 days to live that's it
and like if we're living those lives in
on those days 21,000 days that's it on
earth like in authentically because of
way society should tell us how to think
and act and be or suffer shut up sit
down get you know get serious like get
your head out the clouds like sit down
like that's just sort of the way we've
been kind of stifled to be fully
expressed it's [ __ ] ridiculous the
age of 30 when I got locked up no you
did yeah for kidnapping aggravated oh
yes all that [ __ ] I come on I work hard
you know they won't let me back on the
campus and then finally I got a job I
[ __ ] started as a laborer and I
contacted the company and I took their
estimating courses so I just became the
estimator of this company and they gave
me a truck and a cellphone and I'm like
you know five four three years ago I was
in a hole and Here I am living in
Boulder amongst these people like living
this facade I was not happy yeah at all
Jack and her parents had money insurance
company the whole thing I had a kid
Willa I was not happy at all I'd made my
confirmation at dirty I thought maybe
the Holy Spirit was gonna help me yeah
I joined classes at Naropa Institute of
Buddhist Institute in Boulder I did the
walking meditations I did the talks I
didn't know what it was
yeah just weren't you really living at
living a life that wasn't yours but it
was the life that they told you Ray you
work you mow the lawn on Saturday you go
to your Ma's on Sunday and that's it and
I'm like so this is it touring 65 yeah
and then they give you a watch and they
tell you thank you for your years of
service which is all [ __ ] anyway
it's all I only made millions of dollars
on you that's it that's it that's what
you're trying to tell me all right
and I got it to stand up and shoot July
of 91 and the house wasn't right like
when you live in a house that the
marriage isn't right yeah you can't
force the funk yeah when the last place
you want to be his home like I had two
jobs Wow
I went home at night just basically to
sleep eat breakfast and leave I did that
six days a week so I didn't have to be
home and one day she came to me she goes
I want to move in with my mother and get
separated and I was sad because of the
baby but I was so happy because I could
become a stand-up hmm like I didn't want
to be a [ __ ] roofer and I did nothing
against roofing or nothing against
anybody who does anything yeah it just
was it for me yeah that was a horrible
feeling when you have something when you
work hard to be somebody and you're like
that's why I don't I'm not agreeing with
listen man at 18 you have no idea what
you want to do with your life yeah you
really don't you just well I mean wake
up my ass freak telling me because your
cousin was a underwater biologist so
your honor you're blowing smoke up my
ass telling me uncle Joey I want to be
underwater biologist now comes your
third semester you know like I don't
even like [ __ ] water
I [ __ ] go onto the beach well now
what do you do I mean it starts even
before that totally it starts even
before that like there's this you know
in my my book I share the story of this
guy named Gordon McKenzie who's this
amazing creative designer for hallmark
for 30 years and he's like a creative
and he would go to these elementary
schools to talk to children to basically
seek inspiration from the
and justice because kids are like the
most open vessels of creativity you can
are not [ __ ] full of piled on
societal shame that they can still
actually come up with interesting
creative ideas so he would basically go
to the elementary school and kids and
just talk to them so we'd go to you go
to these kindergarten kids and he would
be like alright who here is an artist
who here is an artist and every single
kid left out of their chairs and like oh
me me me their hands waving flying all
these kids are just freaking out being
like I'm an artist then he went to the
first graders who here is an artist
half the kids raised their hands like
very state stable like not like ah like
they're just like that then third fourth
fifth graders got by the time about a
sixth grader is one person have raised
darting eyes back side to side like
feeling very uncomfortable that you know
he or she was the only one who you know
lifted up their hand to be an artist and
so just that study just showed that as
we get like like every single moment of
our lives from the point where born were
sort of like hammered of like shut up be
quiet sit down stop talking this this
this is how it should be like you know
like put your likes get like this that
you know like don't talk out of turn
like you know don't make eye contact
with strangers and just like non-stop
and so by the time you're like past
sixth grade you're already all the light
and the shine and the effervescence and
the artistry and the creative and the
whoever you are is not a lot of ways
unless you really focus personal reasons
I refuse to go to a restaurant I have to
wait on line yeah you tell me I have to
wait on line I do not go to your
restaurant like when I go to Austin
Texas
and they have people that wait on line
see if $8 an hour
I refuse that I don't want to do
business with you Wow I do not want to
do but I don't think you're cool I do
not think you're chic I think you're a
piece of [ __ ] cuz if I'm hungry you're
there to feed me not to be cool by
having one guy cut me get four [ __ ]
[ __ ] in there making sandwiches
yeah I'm very against when my mother
died my internal system broke down and
even though it's a shitty things to
happen it taught me a lot about life
that you don't really have to pay
attention like I drove with our eyes and
pretend you
in LA Wow people pulled me over
otherwise okay I'm finally one cop gave
me a ticket and I was forced to go in
and I got the license and they said well
what are you talking about
you don't need arises they said give us
two 15 and you have to come back with a
life and so give us four twenty five and
go enjoy your life you know when I fly I
get in the first-class Lane first-class
I don't give a [ __ ] do you when you get
there make you stand in the other Lane
you're there you're there so I was never
really into [ __ ] waha rules yeah I
was ten I was given a decision by my
mother it was very plain and simple I
said we could do this my way or we could
do this your way I'm gonna give you all
the rope in the world that means you got
up in the morning on your own you
prepare your clothes
hmm your bed is made you get your own
breakfast I will give you money to buy
your own breakfast no I will get up and
make it for you but will you come home
we have to vacuum you have to clean your
room you have to earn your keep
she would beYOU know in the 70s you had
to go to the water company and pay the
bill you had to go to the phone company
right no you had to go to the bank to
pay the mortgage I was in charge of all
those things so that was my little side
hustle and she would leave me the [ __ ]
alone once she died at 16 it's very
rough for me like when my mother died I
got offered to move in with friends of
mine
I couldn't move in with them because I
had a curfew you can't go backwards now
right I never had a curfew but the rule
wasn't like you call every hour yeah so
what you do that's what you do you call
it but so what's in them where you got
doing what a friend of mine that they
had no cares okay I'd see him out all
the time they were an Italian family
yeah I mean like rules are rules are
important like rules are important to a
degree but then like what is the rules
that you apply yourself [ __ ] go play
like if you eat pineapple on pizza
you know I would do that branch Buffalo
they do with blue cheese that toy was
meant to do
listen I you want to do [ __ ] rants no
I believe in rules for certain if you're
Tunisian make Tunisian pizza don't let
me see you make salad pizza very
international flavored open yeah but I'm
still I'm excited I've listened I love
the challenge I'll take it I'm taking it
all just teasing no no listen I'm stuck
seriously no hey please so impressed
with you as a person as a woman and you
know just everything that's why I wanted
to have you on the show
oh my gosh and I love your product I
love that you gave us them Sylvia were
you we came through for you yeah coz
every week I tell people you go wash
like I'm that type of [ __ ] on a
plane oh look at your same dog this time
I let you slide next time you better
[ __ ] the owner or not cuz you're
insulting everybody you know Matthew
McConaughey does not wear deodorant
you know John what's the other guy
that's hanging out with Keita the guy
that's going broke [ __ ] Pirates of the
Caribbean giant interweb the other
because they think it's cool I'm the
type and then she worked with Kate
Hudson Kate Hudson brought him deodorant
and he stopped talking to Kate Hudson
you know some people do [ __ ] in this
town because they think it's chic or
it's whatever yeah yeah I don't play
that [ __ ] you gotta watch she has three
times a day it's in the Bible the Koran
I mean Bible we every religious sauce
cleanliness is next to godliness isn't
that the truth it's true the truth I
mean they edit it out yes yes
specifically like over the years the
Corinthians took got ass like Jesus
walked all day can you imagine what
Jesus asked not like you know since the
time I'm 15 I had a friend this is why I
fell in love with your product and this
is the new [ __ ] campaign for your
product
since I'm the age of 13 no 15 me and
Mike running 16 we would sit on the
corner smoke pot talk about we guys
would talk about but every 11 P
for one of us would always pop that up
and go could you imagine what that
person's [ __ ] like we do this for
years even now on the phone Wow watch
the baseball game can you imagine what
that [ __ ] job says something
something something you know and will
die on the phone so this day we still a
couple of weeks ago I was watching the
UFC fightin my wife was in the [ __ ]
living room we had a babysitter and I'm
watching this girl McKenzie dirt but
Kenzie turns got the best ass and MMA
she's a UFC fighter let me show you this
girl okay yeah she jacked she's not my
mom she's just Brazilian California
smile it's just really pretty but she's
an MMA fighter she's a UFC fighter she's
fighting is that where you're really
fighting or yeah she's really [ __ ]
fight so it's so scary that uh like I'm
not you know I wasn't watched it look at
girls asses I'm killing time with the
babysitter and McKenzie turn is fighting
and I see her slow the girl against the
other fence and Mackenzie's are asked
dirt her ass is just oh look at her
smile she sent me a message the tummy
she's gonna kick my ass look at this
girl smile jitsu check beautiful she's
Brazilian gorgeous all right she's got
the best ass in the business huh and I
am sitting there watching Facebook and
it keeps asking me what's on your mind
cuz Facebook really asks you what's on
your mind if you look at it and I wrote
down I wonder what McKenzie turned to as
I was gonna smell like after this fight
and like two days later how is in every
MMA journal like this but they kicked me
off a Facebook for a few days it was
[ __ ] hilarious
back to her I guess what she started
doing putting up more as videos cuz
she's got the bus she pull out a video
of her dancing two days after I said she
the best ass in the world she put out a
video of her with tight yoga pants
wiggling her ass like Shakira she's a
[ __ ] freaking app I've got a word for
that's a Brazilian jiu-jitsu guy they've
told her that what I said she [ __ ] it
up that she showed her ass now
I love that child I love that she's got
great ass - oh she yeah really
no woman just have great ass oh yeah bet
the movi you just sniff it you just hold
it and sniff that [ __ ] note
before - she [ __ ] want to eat that
monkey with that little Arab gyros smell
to it you know I'm saying when you open
it up and you can hear the Arab in there
except I must a yoga [ __ ] you read some
good yoga [ __ ] after an hour and a half
that sweaty [ __ ] yoga [ __ ] ripe
it's like a [ __ ] goji berry [ __ ] it's
Thanksgiving weather can they find your
book oh forget the gourd McCormick store
that's so we Snuffy [ __ ] this smells
like goji berries there's nowhere else
to go Amazon it's called disrupt her
think you're checking on Amazon I love
you but I mean I mean like this is more
of a male audience right so I'd be Ted
but they don't give a [ __ ] okay great
yeah okay great I put a lot of women on
the show okay cool but they probably
have been more or less you probably care
more about their [ __ ] their [ __ ]
home listening to a podcast that means
they're single that means there's a
problem that means a girl suck your dick
and call it a woofer listen when I was
21 I had a girl that would suck my dick
swallowing this keep sucking and then
after like four swallows she'd go
you came four times she was tremendous
and one day we're on the bar drinking
and she looked me in the face she goes I
love sucking your dick but you got a
little wanker you ask him and we're
still friends but we still talk I just
talked to the last week she was in
Nashville she asked me where to go eat
chicken I sent to the Hattie B's but she
looked me in the face when I was 20
she goes we asked I was got a little
weight to it you gotta take care of it
and that changed my life after that I
doubled up on me [ __ ] I got the hand
washed the towel I got a little loofah I
like to scrub my [ __ ] with just to
take out the Dingle berries and the [ __ ]
not a loop that's so good you have to
I'm proud of you laughter I'm actually
like Jack my ass with Irish Spring and
then sticking the town and it still has
bang of [ __ ] white castles like it
don't smell like real ass
it smells like there was ask that your
ass ain't clean how long did it take you
until you invented this new special
loofah like what how old were you I'd be
about I was on the road and I didn't
like stick in the water the towel you
know like when you wash yeah now you
have to always do you have to wash your
face and then wash you ass because what
if you wash you ask them wash your face
that's [ __ ] disgusting
you got like a little brown light spot
it they get they think your father
Cherokee in the intro so you gotta watch
everything perfect you gotta watch
everything first happy you know how
thick a [ __ ] a [ __ ] wash towel is
yeah it's thick you can stick up to our
towel up your ass like an you can stick
like an inch and turn it around you
might as well go to a gay bar cos you
halfway there
a [ __ ] fit look at this [ __ ]
salami finger now wrap an inch towel so
I'd be in the bathroom finger banging
like washing my ass I got a comedy show
I might get lucky you know I know I'm
never using those towels again at the
hotel I love it at the hotel you wash up
with the towel at the end how these are
getting here [ __ ] don't you use that
[ __ ] what you just made with soap you
use a hand towel and I'm not really you
get beat up in prison
like if you use just a bar of soap in
prison though Beach of black people will
beat you why black people hate when you
take a shower without [ __ ] a towel
you have to have a towel wash your face
first get you just get your nose get
your lips what did you want a towel
after and then you wash you trying to
happen then you help your grandmother
that's the brown state issue there's no
black Browns so then I came up with the
loofah well he sticks it in there cuz I
mom yeah you have to stick it in a
little bit just to get there because
it's not you ever go out you ever wipe
your ass and you leave the house and a
half hour later your ass is spicy like
your ass starts to burn a little bit you
like something happen and you go back in
the bathroom and you have wiped you
still got a little blue [ __ ] that's
happened everybody will you go out like
a half-hour later yes a spicy my ass is
on fire and then you go down there
wiping you're like [ __ ] I didn't wipe
right or you wiped correctly but there's
always that after well you never went
using dry paper I'm just saying it's
true
to be just you I know for a fact with
twitchy I don't have no have to after
foliage with with a bit with a bidet
yeah with the midday when I hit you it
takes away the spicy yeah that's the
thing
the spicy ass is a little bit of [ __ ]
that stays in the canal but the fecal
matter
it's like McDonald's I was telling this
mama luckily a every hamburger you buy
has a little piece of fecal matter on ah
when they did that movie about the meat
they found fecal matter on the burgers
yeah because none of them are washing
their hands or wiping their asses on a
tray toilet paper you install them in
restaurants I know we're trying working
on it people are still weird a pile to
wash your hands and your ass with like
people would weigh up super down
people are super day know exactly what
your hands and your ass let me ask you
this yeah you advertising gay
publications oh you know I think this
would be huge the gay community oh no I
have a whole campaign which I really was
called be a better bottom like like you
know cuz like the book no that's okay
okay I can go bottom means you get [ __ ]
you you know see a better bottom Ellen
like you're the bottom like is like you
know there's a time is better bottom
it's all about the tightness of the
[ __ ] in the clinic you know the 70s
they would stick their fingers up their
ass and you would sniff their fingers
called the gay salute
at that gay club a lot of people don't
know that they would stick their fingers
up their ass that was like a sample you
got like a sample of ass like we're
dancing together together dicks and all
said I would stick my finger up my ass
first and give you a sample of the
muffler it's like when you go to the
supermarket they give you a piece of
salami same thing you just are my ass
and then you dance and rub stick a
finger up your ass and maybe scratch
your ball for you and put a bulk to me
and I get an ass and ball at the same
time and then I get aroused I don't know
true this is true swear I swear to God I
need a bad boy when I was a kid that
[ __ ] say they stuck their finger fast
let somebody else smell it's disgusting
we usually stick their finger up their
own ass and give it a sniff but I know
women who get turned down when you don't
take a shower like when you have armpit
smell they they want that animal thing
so think about it there's a guy out
there that before he [ __ ] in the ass he
wants you to Stu you think that like
something I can see a guy going I love
you is so hot you little motorcycle suit
I want you to stick your finger yes and
let me smell it and you're like I've
never done that before I'm gonna [ __ ]
haha who's you know daddy's [ __ ] well
you know I'm all about experimentation I
really am
I don't know I don't know about that
particular one but I definitely you know
all about experimentation well that's a
completely different podcast I love you
Mickey I'm happy you came out thanks
wanna bring you want to promote
push I wanted to bring you on so they
could see who you were and what you were
about that you're a real person you're a
fun woman you have no [ __ ] boundaries
whatsoever
tell them what you different party for
your wedding uh I I okay tell you [ __ ]
okay it happened people went witnesses
yeah great now I'm hungry for the
chocolate yeah great I had we had a
three-day love festival
this is real chocolate organic with
gluten-free so we had a little it's
pretty good right not bad anyway a lot
of Trader Joe's now I know I hate oh
well so I don't we had a three day love
festival and at and on the Saturday
night the day we got tonight we got
married we had a celebration we're at
like around 11:30 at night right before
the dance party you know there was an
offering of psychedelics or party favors
at a Bulls stuff like that just to kind
of get the party going what the in-laws
think they were they were in bed for
sure I mean like most of my friends in
our Burning Man you know like we love
you know like expanding our perspectives
like you guys are right now what Joe has
been doing
he's entrepreneurs well he started a
company called tribute which is imagine
if you wake up on your birthday and you
open your computer and you get an email
and then you press play on this email
and it's a video of every one of your
friends and family telling you why they
love you and how you've been making
their life and so so what do you created
this is a really cool platform that
collects videos and compiles them into a
simple montage so it collects videos
from multiple sources you can create
like you would call me to say put a
video up for Kiwi as a birthday yes
see we watched that monkey I know it
would be it would be like all of her
friends and your family coming together
otherwise like reserves
yeah but cuz otherwise like you have to
collect okay text me the video hey Oh
use text in the wrong way oh it's
pixelated oh is your Dropbox no no he is
cheese he's half he's half Jewish white
boy white boy
really my boy races in in Maui yeah but
he's like he's got flavor for sure yeah
she's got flavor yeah
you offered for the holidays for how
long - [ __ ] oh yeah we have a a code
which is what was the code again muffler
muffler yeah the car cuz what's a
muffler Joey good [ __ ] that's right
that's a different way of saying about
it
wash your muffler why I'm in the party
so yeah you use power use code muffler
for I think it's like 15% off whatever
you want yeah I love you you always
welcome oh my god I think you're a
[ __ ] fascinating woman I love it
I wish I could raise my daughter to be
like you oh my god she'll be my intern
you have a great sense of humor I mean I
still remember talking to you about the
product and telling you what I wanted to
do I'm dying to do that we're doing it
I'm like it's just craziness how most
people would shut you down
I believe that the Internet is going
into an r-rated world yeah we need to be
there I think that commercials are gonna
be a little push to hand a little bit
more yeah I think the victim or you know
push the hand a little bit more
something mm-hmm and that's what we
wanted to do but you know a thing called
sag and the unions in there are fun and
we're waiting tell us when listen man
I'm doing the voice-over that's what
just call me before the thing they've
been going through hell this was
supposed to shoot this is supposed to
shoot October 29th
what's the day's day well wait let's
thank people oh my god every day is like
nightmare
you don't know what's going on I don't
I'm mother Union guy yeah I just wanna
shoot movies - [ __ ] you and you had to
join the union yeah for the second time
you gotta enjoy the new town like he
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want you
could shoot him getting a [ __ ] dick a
possessed and nobody gives a [ __ ] cuz
he's non-union don't let you do the
first one for free and the second one
for
so you could shoot a sad commercial with
Lee the first for this free
the first series would be free the next
time he gets a job before he steps on
that [ __ ] said he'd better paid
unless is a non-union unless it's an
onion commercial I can't do not uni cuz
I'll get fined
oh wow I give you we shot a nine uni
commercial but you showed it in Tunisia
bland there would work got it we shot a
commercial and we shot it in Japan and
we aired in Japan it would work huh here
I'm gonna call with it a [ __ ] year
and they won't call you don't send you a
bill Wow and that bill will be
extraordinary like you look at it and go
what [ __ ] just happened you know I had I
had a par with sag 15 years ago for
firing I got fired but I did working
days and I wanted to get paid for those
two days I was looking for 1260 dollars
do you know a year later the guy caught
me because I had no beef with you
because I just want to release the movie
the SAG won't let me because they find
me $28,000 I said so if you give me 12
sorry I'll just put the 12 in my account
or whatever the [ __ ] the son was - wait
- I don't know what it was I'll sign the
paperwork and you can release your movie
Wow
sag had added so many penalties on
$2,400 oh yeah it was 2,400 a week then
it was like $28,000 years ago years ago
which is worth like hundred thousand you
know years ago yeah literally old child
support my daughter in Colorado then
they called California ago yeah yo sixty
thousand miles ago no [ __ ] way it was
sixty thousand miles I've been paying
635 since Jesus my [ __ ] Chicago how
the [ __ ] do I was sixty thousand miles
yeah maybe I said 600 one months maybe
the agreement one year she said I didn't
get to check at first my ex-wife tried
to rob even my wife's on the count
so she went to the place where I bought
all the money artists and did the math
then we took it down and then we called
then it was over she was over 18 I got a
bill one day from La Sante at sixty
thousand dollars my god if I grant stays
at the house of mouse
I called that way they said yeah gotta
pay a 16 mm I called an attorney said
bring me five thousand I'll get it down
for you
my wife said hold on let's call Colorado
you know how much I owed 140 [ __ ]
down
no California had taxed on all the
additional tax on their own because my
wife the dummy that she was filed in
California at the end just to cover her
ass I was paying child support why would
you do something like that so how'd you
fix it I just paid Colorado a check and
it went away
Oh $140 Colorado said send the money
tomorrow so that you send it tomorrow
for years I was getting checks from sag
with money getting taken out for years
so now I gotta pay me so all of a sudden
I started getting three four hundred
from everybody Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you Wow my
wife called everybody she's an
accountant and everybody sent this back
on money oh yeah
it's a while you don't cover your ass
you know that right now today I could
walk into sag after building into lost
checks right now but I'm so lazy I
haven't done it I used to do it every
year I'll walk into sag after and I
guarantee there's 20 checks with me they
know where I live they know where to
bill me they know where to send my
residuals but if the director sends a
check from a long time ago or something
date they'll send it to the wrong
address right I have to go down and I
guarantee directed I'll go down there in
a week just to prove you guys I'll come
back yeah with $3,000 and checks that
they haven't sent me because they sent
it or the wrong address
go do that but even though they send me
bills because remember sag sends you a
quarterly bill and then they send you a
yearly we want a percent and a half or
you take there like the mob
so after you pay the news January first
you get another one before you get that
[ __ ] card you gotta pay a percent and
a half or whatever you made that yeah so
and then they want twenty to twenty one
thousand to get insurance you know buddy
Vic's you gotta suck to get twenty one
[ __ ] thousand and a thousand of
costar that's twenty one Harvey
Weinstein dicks and a thousand and then
don't pay that for co-star no more no
co-stars make no co-stars ain't making
like 800 750 laugh to get level one
insurance it's thirty three thousand
dollars you have to make you know Brad
Pitt makes in one [ __ ] movie yeah
Brad Pitt don't even use that insurance
but two working waitresses and stuff
like that so if you don't get that three
hundred hours like that
thirty-one thousand thirty three
thousand they penalized you for the
insurance like I'm good cuz I'm vested
[ __ ] them I was available for ten years
and you know it to work steady and get
maintained number two and then you get
none level two for life so now my work
it's because then they'll give me vision
they give me a mental health yeah and
they give me acupuncture I get
acupuncture on my plant so all you give
a [ __ ]
Wow yeah one acupuncture a month I get
to that's great I love that gives a [ __ ]
sticking a needle in my ass to see what
happens just one little Japanese naval
Chinese law do it yourself myself I
can't [ __ ] well whoever you can pay a
chiropractor $20 and the acupuncturist
you pay him an extra twenty and they'll
just tell you you sure yeah I'm sure I
want to feel what an acupuncture feel
feels like in my head these people do
anything lately there's an acupuncture
treatment 3d
well they don't put it in there do they
no I don't pulling you dictate the
needles for erectile dysfunction to
raise testosterone it's a it's a it's a
painful process because you have to do
acupuncture through your feet but I had
a lady my lady I was with her for 12
years
my acupuncturist but then she moved to
Marina del Rey and it's too much so I
like to go up here but me and her got
pretty personal
after years I would ask her what
ailments people were coming for and she
told me once she got cubed I came in
here one time he wanted to get his dick
hard
so it took three weeks for me to give
him needles do you gonna she goes do you
know he came back two weeks later and
said undo it yeah because I was getting
too many ions like the Chinese they
don't like do it Chinese people don't
[ __ ] around they have a thing if you go
into a Chinese pharmacy like a real
traditional they have this black stuff
it's called my plow something that's a
thin it's like eatin like thin rock Wow
that's in geographical Blache that's
good I'll tell you right the thing go
for the white Chinese people they got a
Wang till they're [ __ ] even in Japan
Okinawa is where people live the order I
think they just switched it something
else became Okinawa had a beat you live
to a hundred is to own this place where
you live in the country because you eat
fresh yeah okay yeah blue zone and you
can't just move that you have to get a
recommendation to move to hope okay now
you just can't move to hope enough right
and I watch the show once about
bodybuilding and Okinawa how big it is
for men they have a 65 to 75 year old
league and the 75 to 85 year old league
and they were asking women that age like
do you date these guys like oh [ __ ] yet
we date them I got like two boyfriends
we have sex is [ __ ] like that so I'm not
we have this conversation that's all
started with how old - she I love ya
thank you very much for coming on happy
Thanksgiving happy Thanksgiving to you
too
have you won a nice [ __ ] portable
birthday the best in the business
stop walking around with yeah it's dirty
all right there's no reason to walk
around with a sniffy ass smelly ass you
want more confidence when you take your
dick out you want to go you know what
I'm free
I want to know that she licks my nut
she's not gonna get [ __ ] a whiff of
his [ __ ] dirty muffler this does not
have to exist anymore right now go -
hello - she's calm right now they have
an array of different portable bidet
starting and sixty million dollars and
they use code muffler and they use code
muffling at 50
miss 11 you have a 60 day guarantee yeah
60 day guarantee you're not gonna need
it because if Glee and my [ __ ]
[ __ ] wash you haven't tapped out
yours isn't gonna be this is 300
pounds-plus odors because that water
sprinkler at one time he's got to say I
can't take this no more what's coming
out of his ass is like what's a shoe
that those little kids over there Turkey
what's that [ __ ] big gazebo okay we
sit there with the you're talking about
Iran or something I don't [ __ ] like
this poor lady so go - hello - she's
calm and buy your favorite relative it's
Thanksgiving
it's great Christmas is rubella Brown
Friday yeah Brown Friday well off you go
it's a LeBron fry brown fright we've
Oliver everything's on sale and I want
to say make sure though that hello Toshi
and we have fiber Monday's fiber Monday
[ __ ] 5a monday Brown Friday is the day
you know I'm saying aka Black Friday AKA
jus day that's how we [ __ ] real Jew day
how do you negotiate you don't even need
to be a Jew when I was a kid you go out
the Delancey Street you know what the
Lancie Street is that you know in New
York City thank you you couldn't go on
that blog you had to argue for hours you
we just got on to the practice
negotiation skills and then you go to
Chinatown still Chinese and the Yiddish
believe that I don't walk in there store
for us to have to do business with you
uh-huh
so you gonna rip their hearts out [ __ ]
sneakers but it's like the first one at
first and first the first purchase is
like a so we would go to Chinatown they
gotta like converse business we would
torment two Chinese people
$9.00 too long too long you know you go
high I go la we would talk about them
$10 mine that just a game it's a sport
it's a sport I know I feel the same way
about like negotiating like terms with
my supplier he said when he went to
Israel they're the best a 1/4 Israel and
so [ __ ] Indians are pretty good too
yeah they'll sign you're [ __ ] my
friend hey how old is she doc calm thank
you very well yeah yeah
all right I want to thank Mickey for a
great conversation she's [ __ ] nuts I
love her to death you know I've been
pushing her product for about two years
now and one day she sent me an email and
I saw all the things that she did and I
could tell she's a pretty [ __ ]
amazing broad so what the [ __ ] let's
have her on the podcast and let's have
some fun so supporter over there at
hello - she com any but day they started
69,000 a come in all different colors
let me taste them there's nothing better
than them to clean ass all over the
holidays this podcast is also brought to
you by Ridge wallet comp okay
the rich like I said it's a minimalist
front pocket wallet that helps you
really value eight your everyday carry
all right your old wallet you got a
bunch of pictures and a bunch of
[ __ ] you're carrying them out for
month and years well you really need all
these [ __ ] pictures before you know
talked about you know how much [ __ ]
there is in your wallet that you don't
need you have a look at your wallet
spent gift cards [ __ ] hotel room
receipts keys from a hotel
forget all that the ridge helps you
carry less but always what you need it's
sleek the two metal plates bound
together by durable elastic band you
know let me tell you something this is
the way to go this is the future and it
ensures an options for everyone like I
said it's a front pocket wallet and let
you ditch your bulky wallet its slim its
RFID blocking and it's got a lifetime
guarantee you know why cause it's the
last wallet you're ever gonna buy it
comes in titanium carbon fiber aluminum
and the polycarbonate and over a dozen
different styles and colors I've got the
titanium when when I travel it's [ __ ]
tremendous now what I'm gonna do for you
is this is church family I'm gonna give
you a 10% off with free worldwide
shipping by going to Ridge wallet doc
Thomas last Church that's Ridge wallet
doc
slash Church use code Church Ridge
wallet it's the last wallet you'll ever
buy also I want to give a quick shout
out to my family over that on it doing a
Black Friday sale that starts you ready
for this on Thanksgiving November 22nd
it's the biggest sale of the year you're
gonna get 25% on supplements 18 percent
of fitness including Star Wars and
Marvel or you guys are the Marvel crazy
people all the kettlebells this is your
[ __ ] chance 20% off foods 50% off
DVDs and books and 30% off apparel and
personal care in addition they're gonna
have price cuts and they're gonna have
awesomeness listen they're gonna have
$10 coupons free shipping with premium
gifts on all available items this year
make to 9 2019 your best year your life
by stocking them down the best
supplements in the business go to on
accom slash black friday and press in
church and get the best deal of your
life listen I want to thank Mickey
Agarwal whatever [ __ ] name is I love
her to death don't man it I want to
thank you guys I want to thank Lee I
want to thank myself but most
importantly I want to wish you guys all
the Happy Thanksgiving with your
families and I hope that you're safe and
you enjoy yourself from the bottom of my
heart I appreciate you guys for what
you've done for me if it's not the
[ __ ] C so special it's a new special
out on Netflix I appreciate all the
applause and everything that you guys do
all the love that you show me on that so
have a great weekend have a great
holiday
I'll be back here Monday tip top Magoo
listen I got shows but I don't think
it's left the only tickets you got left
are in La Jolla in the Comedy Store
December 6th and 7th I got the
Bakersfield tumbler temblor Brewing
Company type of bullying company
December 12th and that's it the rest of
the year guys it's all over I got like
snot at the end of December we'll get to
that let's worry about Thanksgiving
let's have a great Thanksgiving I love
you guys see you Monday morning tip top
Magoo right
the [ __ ] rock kick this [ __ ] melee